well it's been a Day of Reckoning here
in Cardiff after a dispute that has
lasted some 18 months or so there's been
negotiations taking place between the
players and the Welsh Rugby Union all
day at the hotel behind me and an 11th
Hour breakthrough on today which was the
deadline set by players where they were
threatening to go on strike and as you
say walk out and not play that vital Six
Nations clash in Cardiff against England
well that now will go ahead after a deal
was reached between the players and the
Welsh at Rugby Union the disagreement
had centered on three points essentially
won a a cap the 60 cap level which is
set by the Union in terms of how many
times they have to appear in test
matches in order to be able to be
selected that has been reduced now to
25. there's also a disagreement over the
contracts um and there's been an
agreement at reach to allow them to have
a choice between fixed contracts and
variable contracts that's about how much
as they get paid as a set amount and how
much is in bonuses that has been agreed
as well as representation on the board
it has been a very turbulent 18 months
in Welsh rugby a sigh of relief we had
some initial reaction from the Welsh
captain kenoans in the last couple of
minutes
with the events of
the last six to eight weeks I think
everybody in Welsh would be really to
pull together now to find the best way
forward
I'm going to do it collaboratively
together to put one should be back at
the top end of world rugby I'm not the
laughingstock which I think we are at
the moment and I think we can do that
with a collaboration that's been agreed
had a strike gone ahead this would have
been an incredibly expensive loss for
the union here in Wales the match on
Saturday is worth around 10 million
pounds to them against England that's uh
excluding the economic impact it will
have for businesses in Cardiff so a sigh
of relief for them the players and the
fans of course uh Warren Gatlin the head
coach for Wales had put off yesterday
the team announcement and canceled uh
part of the training yesterday so this
really did go to the wire we expect him
to announce the team tomorrow but relief
now that that's a contract issue has
been resolved and the freeze on
contracts to allow players right across
Wales to be able to sign new contracts
and continue playing with some
reassurances that'll be lifted next week